and uh okay shall we have a quick guess
ah too late magnus has played one d4
opening with the queen's pawn and uh
which opening will we see from duda will
we see the catalan which magnus uh has
played during the world championship
pontus you mentioned the world
championship being maybe the source uh
his prep of a lot of his preparation
nowadays it is the catalan opening so
one of magnus's strongest openings he's
taking this one seriously and black
catches the pawn very early so a bit of
a spin on the queen's gambit black
temporarily a pawn up but now we will
see a very forcing line black trying to
really force matters in the center of
the board and white's knight jumping
forward okay i was going to say magnus
there might have captured a black form
we might have seen a queen trade and
lots of pieces flying off the board but
no
white now looking for compensation for a
sacrifice pawn with quick development
these knights flying forward and i've
had a little bit of experience in this
opening myself and it's very very scary
for black if you don't know what you're
doing but dude by the speed of which
he's been playing
he seems to know his stuff black's rook
there just backing up at night so
black's still one point up but black's
king uncasted still takes a couple of
moves to run to safety later have you
played against any of these two punters
um
no not really actually you know we
played many times the same tournament
unfortunately
in this world championship last time
when we played in poland for example
yeah i was in the other end of the
tournament
i hardly i only saw my magnus at the
dinners
afterwards
because we i played horrible yeah oh wow
how much do you play these days are you
mostly working with with business
ministries and kids and those
initiatives are you playing a lot as
well yeah chest-wise no i'm not playing
at all more or less anymore
so very very few games in the czech
league maybe i play some games
uh but otherwise i'm too busy with
everything
so i don't play much but i know that
duda plays this line a lot
he always plays this line so is he one
of those players yeah that has those few
openings that he likes to play yeah we
heard him say in the interview that he
doesn't necessarily have one specific
favorite opening but he does have kind
of backups that he relies upon so in the
very biggest matches as sponsors
mentions he does con tend to fall back
on a certain repertoire here with black
he's just trying to be solid just trying
to trade off pieces survive the opening
and uh it makes sense to have kind of a
backbone to your openings uh you don't
want to be freestyling every single game
coming up with a new opening every
single time that just takes too much
time to study too much energy um it's
nice to kind of have something like this
opening where at least he'll know his
stuff he'll know the plans for the next
few moves and uh magnus is the first one
to think yes investing a couple of
minutes and uh whilst magnus is pausing
and considering how he's going to adapt
to duda's surprise well we already have
some selfies to show oh wow and uh yeah
they're very quick off the mark keep
them coming we love them okay and uh
magnus actually playing the most
critical move on the database um
developing the queen putting pressure on
the pawn on b7
so still very well known stuff this
position has been reached before in some
grand master clashes
and now white trying to go for activity
with his queen and white's light square
bishop on a great diagonal but
temporarily the knight is attacked in
the center of the board so magnus will
have to take a time out to deal with
that i think the most usual move as far
as i know is the white knight capturing
black's light squared bishop
and uh yeah
for sure dude has done his homework
there and the variation continues quite
deeply and this has been analyzed by
both players for sure magnus just trying
to find a way maybe to
surprise duda to take him out of uh his
comfort zone but not easy to do that
there's not that much choice here for
white
yeah you're right um one of the main
moves is actually to capture that bishop
there is a second alternative that
magnus might be tempted by and that's
actually to develop the dark squared
bishop and protect the knight that's
under fire
okay so we'll wait to see what magnus
does
defend that night in the center or
initiate more exchanges
stylistically i think magnus would love
to snap off black's bishop seize the
bishop pair maybe get the pawn back
white's queen on this beef can go and
grab a porn but
that would just walk into what uh duda
has prepared
so psychological battle right now
and uh yeah pontus magnus he's from
scandinavia as well did you have some
experience with him playing against him
when he was younger yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i told you some story before when he
was uh
first time when i met magnus he he was
sitting on two pillows
to reach the board
and he was eating raisins all the time
so and the smaller candy and we were
like what is this you know and then he
he we saw the moves that came out they
were strong we were like this kid can't
even reach the board and then he was
playing with the norwegian national uh
youth team against us and the swedish
natural new team we were like well this
kid can't even reach the board
the moves that come out you know uh are
quite strong yeah so but first came
actually he actually lost in that way
because um
we were playing up in this mountain in
gaustop yeah yeah i heard about that
tournament again and then basically
there it was huge delay because the
finnish team they were
late
arriving
so so therefore basically we were
playing this game and magnus actually
since he was so young
it was the round was delayed with three
hours oh wow so we were playing really
late
in the evening and later at night
and he had an equal position against one
of my friends now and and uh our coach
because smug was offered draw and the
coaches
he wanted to take the draw because we
were all tired of this trip you know the
mountain up
and but our coach said no no he's a kid
he's gonna fall asleep
so don't take the draw yes play on
and uh it was too late for magnus so he
actually got tired
because
he was
he was also out of races so
it was out of fuel you can say so so he
lost in the end and that was the first
time i met magnus wow that was nine i
think
oh that's so cool we often talk about
starting late in the day i mean the
players here we saw both of them
starting at 6 p.m yeah maybe that can be
a strategy tyron magnus
maybe that's why he became a night owl
kind of statement
because of that experience yeah you know
now he's totally different i think if
you play at night you you will be the
one who will fall asleep
you need to play magnus in the early
morning i think the best chance this is
a really good chance yeah yeah so
if eight o'clock in the morning yeah
exactly so if young christoph duda wins
uh the candidates and maybe paul says oh
we're gonna we're gonna be hosts for the
next world championship match and the
games will start at 8 a.m in the morning
the only problem is that the magnus will
abdicate this title and not arrive
but but it's it's a good idea yeah
ah we figured it out now you guys how to
beat magnus crawls in a world
championship match
play early in the morning and uh they're
definitely uh spending time to think
here in the opening is this complicated
stuff yeah it's maybe not necessarily
complicated it's still a bit of a
psychological uh it is magnus sleeping
yeah maybe it doesn't look that way it's
a flashback you know yeah looks like
there is an almost magnus this is like
the first time i saw him he has a little
bit more beard
he can actually reach the right he can
also reach the board
so he said he's improving did he
it actually kind of looked like it did
fall asleep the timing here is
incredible is he laughing magnus is he i
think he did fall asleep
okay he's laughing maybe he realized he
just woke himself up maybe he heard your
story pontius
you have to talk to the control room you
know they have to
the players can't hear us
yeah so
yeah i mean duder now having his first
real big think of the game we did see
that night for bishop trade we did see
white capture the black light squared
bishop and now white has the bishop pair
but white's still upon down sorry i'm
just laughing at magnus laughing this
time and uh yeah white is still upon
down but two black pawns under fire if
you look at black's pawn in the center
of the board the d4 pawn that has been
attacked by magnus's last move with his
rook and also the black pawn on the b7
square is actually attacked by white's
queen on the b-file and by white's
light-squared bishop so white will win
his pawn back at some stage duda needs
to find a way to stay active and at
least to
maybe create some compensation for the
fact that white will
be able to trade some stuff off and keep
the bishop pair still very tense but
dude i think he's paused at the right
moment uh this white rook move i'm not
sure how common it is but uh he
definitely needs to work out the path
over the next few times
he's having the time of his life here in
this game well i i think you know he has
the kind of position that magnus excels
at and uh he's got
the bishop pair you know he's got some
pressure
as davis pointed pointing out against
the pawns but i'm a bit puzzled by uh
young crystal studios
pause for thought because
it seems to me like there's only really
one move that you can play and that is
just to defend the pawn in the middle of
the board as opposed to the pawn that's
under attack on b7 yeah so as mentioned
these two pawns under fire um using
white's bishop as well eyeing up this
pawn from a fan if you have to compare
the pawns i think this one is the most
important as you mentioned ivanka if you
for example take a time out to defend
the other pawn i mean i just look so
clumsy and allowing white's rooks to get
active
this is only going to end in disaster
this is a pin and white surely we'll be
able to profit from it so um yeah it
looks really important to defend this
central pawn and instead of the move you
mentioned ivanka may be pushing a pawn
to defend it this way which is look well
this just looks very healthy very
natural dude has defended it with his
bishop instead
okay this looks a bit superficial the
bishop not on a great square here it
could get hit later maybe by a pawn for
example but uh he's hoping that any pawn
pushers will just weaken white's
position and now the bishop will go back
not sure exactly where but for example
if it steps back one square white has
actually weakened himself on this
diagonal for example you can't capture
this pawn now because of a nasty pin
so just a bit of provocation maybe and
magnus has to decide okay whether to
push this pawn maybe he doesn't want to
rush it keep it up his sleeve or whether
to go and capture the other pawn this
time maybe white's queen can take this
pawn we could see for example a queen
trade and
who's better here i think white i don't
know about you guys but i'm just relying
on these two bishops and also
for example after black's rook moves and
the bishop retreats somewhere then white
has a two versus one advantage long term
and uh you could imagine that becoming a
factor
pontus do you like the opening choice
you mentioned due to plays this a few
times
he has played it quite a lot you know
with the c5 he's one of the biggest
advocates of this uh
opening but uh bishop e5 um surprised me
i have to be honest and say this i
thought
i was thinking about bishop c5 because
e5 looks not very nice so i was thinking
about this move but uh
he played bishop he finds that unless
like you say it's trying to provoke like
f4 and those weakening moves or e3 and
then he wants to play as uh
you know those kind of isolated pawn
position so it's one white is going to
do e3 and take on d4 so they will get a
pawn in the center
and then he's going to try to use that
later but
white has a good position so he i think
what
this is interesting bishop e5 and we
will see a little bit more what's uh
if because if you do a move like this i
don't think you you do it at the board i
think
there must be some variation
before that he has seen his preparation
that there might be something you know
uh where he can do bishop e5 provoke f4
so maybe this bishop move he's looked at
something very similar before it's an
idea he's borrowing from a different
position and uh yeah as you mentioned um
i mean this is one of dude's favorite
openings it kind of looks in a way like
we're bypassing the opening and we're
very quickly if magnus chooses the most
natural move capturing here we're very
quickly heading into the end game which
i think would favor magnus so i'm
slightly surprised to see him think i
would just go and capture this pawn
trade the queens off and uh kind of
continue the game but as you mentioned
there pontus the other alternative would
be to try and use the weird position of
this bishop the weird placement to maybe
push some pawns either this one uh
trying to open up the line for the rook
against the queen or to push the bishop
back let's go back to the players magnus
has that choice push pawns or try and
trade off the queens and um it's a
stylistic thing here maybe depending on
his mood
when magnus kind of wakes up and feels a
bit fresher maybe we'll see the moves
come a bit quicker
yeah
and while still waiting for magnus to
take a decision
um i didn't quite get around to
announcing benjamin but uh someone else
who has is sending us a selfie is a neil
young who is actually watching in
australia i get this
four a.m in the morning with his dog
ricky
the neil young i'm wondering
ah let me have a look no
the neil young would have like a blue uh
yeah
i don't think he's australian either
but we do love this neil young as well
we do definitely love this thing and we
also like his dog ricky and here we see
benjamin a big fan of magnus who says go
magnus and uh he's getting ready with
his child yeah i imagine also young
chris of duda has a bunch of fans i mean
chess is huge in poland has a rich
history and now with young christoph
uh playing like he's playing it's
blooming again right in poland it's
really booming as you mentioned some
great players in throughout polish
history
some
i mean really world-class players and
now again just this last few years
there's radik voitershek who's a
fantastic player and uh now dude as well
and
pontius also mentioned the world rapid
championship recently the world rap and
blitz championships they were held in
warsaw poland is starting to organize a
lot of big big tournaments so um i mean
he's one of the catalysts of course duda
but
the scene there growing a lot and
actually just by coincidence the
position has developed a bit white did
indeed go and capture a porn with this
queen we saw the queens disappear and
white's bishop after grabbing a pawn did
actually retreat to the square i
highlighted
i only mentioned this square because
it's kind of the
not the lazy option the simple option i
should say
but then again it does block white's
pawn the white f pawn from going up and
hitting that black bishop in the center
so i am slightly surprised by that
choice of square but meanwhile it is
that battle white has the two bishops
and the queen side majority those two
versus one advantage on the left black
has an extra central pawn
and first black needs to decide what to
do with his king
to castle or not to castle that is the
question points are off so maybe the
king can survive yeah i was going to ask
because a bunch of pieces have already
in move 16 left the board the queens are
off so
it's actually the black king better
place than the white king right now it
would love to stay in the center of the
black king the only question is if you
keep the black king in the center too
long there are bishops the white bishops
could start to maybe throw some checks
at you
you have to really weigh up that
that kind of decision carefully so i
think that's what duda has to decide
right now he has to make a decision with
this king and he has to make it now
before it's too late
uh should we have a vote is black going
to castle where the king is safe but
maybe not being able to help later in
the game or is black going to keep his
king in the center and play with fire
castle it's my vote yeah i think he has
to castle because there is a variation
there after if you move your king to the
center
there is uh
the the pawn there on on the b file can
maybe move a step forward and then the
bishop is going to be extremely annoying
uh that's a little bit scary
from from that diagonal so i i think he
will go for castling okay unless his
calculator is better than me which he
does
well i was about to say just
so you nearly have the answer yeah it's
the commentator's cursed contest
as soon as we say one thing the players
always do the opposite exactly because
yes so i saw this rook movie yes also
that is going to come so you probably
can do this with some tactical things
yeah in this position the check is
coming as we mentioned from this angle
and if magnus does indeed kind of
prepare the check by pushing his pawn
forward then black's rook will move i'm
not sure exactly where but for example
it will centralize itself and when the
check does happen now he can either
block with his bishop or he can even
just step back with the king and the
king i think is far better here than it
would have been if it had castled and
it's just more flexible so why on earth
did young christoph move his king i mean
he could have moved other pieces right
yeah i think he just needed to get this
rook in the game that was the main
priority ah okay the only way to get
that rook in the game is either to lift
the black king off the back rank or for
example to castle as we mentioned and
and castling yet it's just the fact the
king is so far away from the action
later on in the game and it still takes
your rook one more move to kind of
centralize itself or bring itself over
to this left side so um yeah i think
it's a sensible move but it does look a
bit scary spontaneous mentioned because
of white's bishop
may be occupying this diagonal
so we'll see if that's what magnus does
he could also use a different angle
maybe just sliding his bishop forward
one square same idea and also maybe
simultaneously bringing
his rook towards the center all right
well it's definitely having uh magnus
think this move by young christoph duda
so i want to ask you another question
about business meets chess and kids you
told me about something upcoming um
that's called chess to change yeah what
is that oh and we do have that move the
one that you talked about yeah at least
i got one right
very nice
yeah because magnus jumped over my
level i was i was looking forward to
play him and then he just disappeared
so now no we have this chest to change
which is uh
a tournament that we're gonna do on
april 23rd
where we will have uh business guys and
and and uh celebrities um that that uh
likes chess
playing together online with kids
uh african chess talents from from
four backgrounds uh that that's so
they're gonna play a hand and brain
tournament together oh that's my
favorite yeah yeah it's it's really nice
but it's actually gonna be online yeah
it's gonna be online so someone will sit
in silicon valley to play and someone
else will sit somewhere else and you
have the kids you know some kids in
nairobi other one in lusaka in zambia
and so and some in mombasa so they sit
over
some in nigeria so they sit in different
countries and then they play hand and
brain together and so you're gonna team
up one of the kids with one of the
celebrities or business people and who's
going to be the hand and who's going to
be the brain
well
that's interesting they can maybe they
can choose yeah we will see you know
because
there's always a problem with this
you know people some people don't want
to be in the spotlight
so they prefer to just say a piece you
know because it's easier yeah because
you know if you say a piece you know
then it's up to the one who plays
actually to fix it yeah so we will see
actually about this one oh interesting
but it's a it's a
very fun tournament you know and we have
done we've done some like this before
but this is uh
it's it's also very tricky when you
organize this because of the time zone
differences you know yeah and also the
difference sometimes in internet quality
can be a challenge you know all about
that yeah
technical problems but it's it's uh so
we are looking now for
more uh business guys and celebrities
that wants to take part because it works
like this that they play together and
then basically
it develops into a sponsorship so the
the business guys they they sponsor the
kids up so they can actually you know
get school fees
food housing uh
you know clean water with a shower and
also of course chest equipment and then
be able to also go to go to chest
formats so it develops into a mentorship
like this fantastic initiative looking
forward to that okay we do have a few
moves on the board anything dramatic
happening um almost but uh dude spotted
magnus's threats and we saw white's
bishop actually go to the edge of the
board he was skewering the two black
rooks the two black rooks on the same
diagonal white's dark square bishop was
eyeing them both up but black's knight
galloped over to the rescue and blocked
that white dark square bishop's diagonal
so i don't think we'll see magnus carson
make a trade any time soon of white
capturing that black knight because that
would just end in opposite colour
bishops and
white really needs to rely on the bishop
pair having them both together uh in
order to create something here but duda
really alerts spotting magnus's threat
and i think it's time for magnus to
start bringing his rooks over
if all the rooks disappear i think white
has a quite stable advantage but uh it's
not maybe easy to challenge black's rook
on the c file black has control on the
only open line the only fully open line
at the moment and if white challenges
that rook at the moment black will just
back that rook up and one set of rooks
might disappear but not both
so duda at the moment just uh playing
solid he's just trying to keep
everything covered and okay magnus
switches tact he just
retreats the bishop giving a check and
now the black king really has to move
you can't anymore block with the black
bishop because then
you lose protection of black's pawn in
the center of the board black has to
move his king and again question for her
for all of us is he going to kind of
just go back to the top of the board
relatively safe or is he going to move
over
and uh is he going to continue advancing
that black king
magnus just asking questions i guess
that's all you can do in a position like
this just
kind of force your opponent to make
difficult decisions every time and the
king does go back this time though it's
on a light square so maybe later on
white's light squad bishop can try to
target it
okay so who would you guys prefer to be
if you walked into a room and you saw
this board would you choose white or
black photos whites right definitely
white is better but uh
you know dude i see
i mean this is quite normal for him he
many times ends up in positions like
this
and then he wins sometimes as well
he's a good fighter
yeah his name actually online uh on
several chess websites is polish fighter
3000
because he knows he yeah he knows often
he doesn't necessarily outplay the top
players but he fights really well and
yeah as you mentioned he tricks them
later or he kind of confuses them and um
right now he's solid and the reason you
say white's better than pontus is i
guess
also white at any moment can kind of
bail out why can uh for example as we
mentioned go for that bishop for nitrate
and just go for opposite color bishops
so it feels like white is playing for
two results a win and a draw black is
the one who's kind of just still
fighting for that equality yeah
so definitely
and it's interesting position maybe it
will double the rooks i think yeah
on this file yeah yeah i'm predicting
all the moves now yeah i'm improving i'm
improving
yeah so the idea behind this one uh it's
two or three moves deep but the idea as
uh mentioned is to actually keep the
rooks on the board and double them up on
this d file stack up the rooks together
for example if black
just takes the time out just pushes the
pawn just a non
kind of helpful move and white will
double the rooks and now there is an
idea of undermining black's pawn in the
center
utilizing a potential pin on this d file
so yeah it's just a couple of moves deep
but
maybe magnus has that luxury it's not
clear how black improves his pieces uh
white's plan is rook across and then
pushing upon
how does black react meanwhile the
problem is anytime you bring your knight
back to the center you lose
a tempo right the white bishop comes
again with the skewer on the two black
rooks and the black knight is forced to
retreat and then one can continue with
the plan once more
yeah
my suggestion for answering magnus's
plan would be simply just to sidestep
with the rook you know and say yes white
is great on the d-line but you can carry
on looking at my pawn and i'm going to
take control of the open sea line and uh
every time that my
my pawn is attacked or my my bishop is
attacked i'm just going to maintain the
protection of that pawn
yeah whether black can kind of maintain
this duo and keep them intact and it's
going to be a bit of a weird situation
where black's rooks look fantastic
stacked up on this open file but white's
rooks do have some purpose even though
they're kind of staring at this really
kind of sufficiently defended black pawn
once white opens up this central line by
kind of levering and forcing this trade
then white also has an open file so uh
it looks like they're a bit kind of
i mean not the best pieces in the world
yeah maybe not useless but just it seems
um
like too much uh too little work for two
very strong bishops exactly i mean this
should carry heavier load definitely
these i mean these two rooks they're
worth ten combined but they're staring
and they're kind of blocked by just a
mere foot soldier just this one pawn uh
but yeah once you get rid of this pawn
for example again if black just makes a
kind of lazy move then once these pawns
get traded off then suddenly these rooks
will come to life later uh on this file
so yeah interesting plan by magnus the
more i look at it the more i like it
this rook lift not obvious but the plan
is quite a sophisticated one ah yeah and
uh whilst we're waiting for the players
to make those moves i again i bowled
over by your selfies and this time
carles zalaiti is uh supporting duda and
he's watching from the netherlands
just before the sleeping incident and uh
duda actually playing a very aggressive
move actually diving down with the rook
onto that ideal second row
ah it's a nice impressive
move
i mean i i haven't calculated anything
to it but it looks good yeah visually it
looks very good but there are no direct
threats we do say that rooks they should
belong on the second rank if you're
black or as white the seventh rank
because that's where all the targets are
that's where all the pawns are you can
kind of just snack on all the pawns
later on uh but right now all of white's
pawns on the second rank are actually
defended so this black rook i think it's
just trying to and uh dude is trying to
annoy magnus more than anything he's
also trying to pin down white's rook in
the uh in the bottom left corner to the
defense of some pawns
um so that's the type of move that when
my opponent plays it i'm just like ah
get out of my face just i want to trade
you off i want to force you to retreat
but it's not so easy to do that for
magnus right now
and uh yeah very impressive move by duda
just
as mentioned he's just a fighter and
he's fighting to stop white continuing
his plan if white's rook in the corner
does move now then the white pawn on a2
would just simply fall off yeah
and i was just gonna say you know i was
uh and your idea is in operation magnus
does not like that rook on the second
row and once it traded and uh duda
insisting there's gonna be a rook that
whatever you
you want in the matter and uh
he gave pontus's plan of doubling the
route it's like we're
good
yeah i was actually thinking about going
there to that square directly because
now he has actually provoked rook c2 so
if he provoked the rook to go into a
second rank
uh and i was thinking actually that he
should go
to the square where the rook is directly
but uh so i'm i'm trying to figure out
how this can be a big ah okay so he was
probably trying to do the bishop move
central there
that was probably what he was trying to
do so black's last move uh actually
prevents white's idea as you mentioned
the bishop into the center just hitting
this white uh hitting the blackboard
kicking it away and uh for example if
black had moved then now you force black
to make a decision and uh run away or
make a trade but uh this was prevented
and uh magnus this is a very typical
magnus type of movement yeah just doing
nothing yeah doing nothing but in a
useful way uh so just improving the
white king slightly taking it off the
back rank just in case there's some
checks later and also slightly closer
towards the center and uh later magnus
might decide to open up the position or
he might just maybe push some pawns
first those would be very typical magnus
moves as well one move i'm waiting for
magnus to play is to push the a pawn
forward this is something we see here in
nearly every game from him uh nowadays
and uh yeah still tense it's not clear
what black does because white has really
well guarded this second rank uh using
his rook now and eventually we'll see
some traits yeah and dude i was making
my move that i was just gonna suggest
because uh you suggested all these plans
of uh advancement for magnus
and uh if duda just sits there and waits
he's just so slowly gonna get a worse
and worse position so i think therefore
to challenge magnus's superiority you
kind of have to also
push pawns and grab some space yeah the
general rule is that when you're facing
against the bishop pair you need to
accelerate the player you can't let
white for example slowly just improve
push pawns trade off all the rooks you
need an active plan and you need to
challenge white before the bishops gain
in power and bishops do gain in power as
the game goes on so you might as well
speed things up and this is actually a
bit of a threat now by duda he does want
to push his pawn forward
team up his central pawns
maybe then white has to either now
before it's too late push this pawn in
the center and undermine the head of
black's pawn chain
the central pawn or maybe the safety
first option would be to trade one set
of rooks and then offer a second trade
but even this is not so clear wow okay
magnus just ignoring both of those
options and instead pushing upon he's
trying to open up lines for his bishops
also now making it impossible for black
to push in the center because then the
pawn next to it would simply fall off
the one thing you definitely don't want
to do as black here is trade on the
square either because suddenly
there are threats this is a pin black's
isolated well not quite isolated pawn
but the wheat pawn in the center
it's not so easy to deal with it just
maybe you can defend it with the king
but it feels a bit wrong but but there
are big issues
malcolm magnus's move is actually very
clever because
if you don't trade that pawn
and uh say you so you reinforce it
what is the response going to be after
pawn takes pawn this is a good question
ivanka this is actually what black
ideally wants to do but suddenly you're
walking into the danger zone suddenly
this king is checked and it can't use
the dark squares remember the bishops
are doing this kind of crisscross um
kind of motion that we've seen before
and suddenly the black king has to step
into the eye line of the white rooks and
that looks uh
not quite suicidal for black but uh very
very scary at least uh so probably will
move the king no yeah oh he does take
the point yeah then there's something
with the knight into the center but ah
maybe this is uh so he's trying to go
with this king first no to yes behind
the bishop and then his the knight is
coming to lif to to behind oh sorry
coming here
yes into the center and it's going to
start attacking the white bishop and
actually he does it immediately your
idea there pontus so not taking a time
out to defend uh do that instead of just
defending this pawn with his king he
counter attacks against the white bishop
so we could see a crazy material balance
here if white had taken this pawn knight
takes bishop the key thing is that
black's rook at the bottom guards this
bishop so black actually has two pieces
for a rook which favors black here of
course the piece is better than the rook
so magnus decides uh he just has to run
away this bishop under fire has to run
and okay he's gonna maybe snake back
this way
and i'm just seeing the tweet from um
yurki is it uh city in finland
finns are not late this time
hi to finland we do love pins
that was a good way to finish
well yes i'm probably
a big enemy of finland
the happiest country in the world
finland we all want to live there yep
all right well
this white bishop retreating i thought
you didn't want to retreat at this time
yeah um i think maybe the white bishop
had just done its job there and maybe
it's more important the biggest priority
now to try and eliminate this black
knight or at least put some pressure on
the black knight and duda he just
ignores it he just pushes a pawn
covering some light squares and now big
question does white go and capture this
knight in the center of the board with
his bishop you can actually force
black's pawns to be doubled in the
center now if you do capture the black
knight
but you do lose the bishop pair you lose
a lot of quality in your position
still this white this black rook sorry
on the second rank it's really annoying
it totally is annoying so there's also
another candidate move which is you know
to go back to a plan that i think pontus
you mentioned and that was to attack the
rook but uh magnus is saying no
he's actually
pushing
forward with his pawns on the left side
and presumably the idea is actually to
step forward sorry step backwards with
the bishop and uh interrupt the two
rooks's communication with each other
yeah so that key c5 square now white has
a grip on it and uh yeah magnus he
actually did something very similar
yesterday in the first game against ding
he pushed his pawns and it was very very
effective but then he pushed them a bit
too far so you've got to be careful when
you push pawns like this they could
become weak
but they might just uh gain in strength
if they run down the board or they might
also control some key squares
uh yeah interesting decision that from
magnus taking quite quickly the players
now down to around three minutes each
this position despite the fact it's an
end game we could see some big mistakes
strategically also tactically um no
blunders yet no big mistakes from either
player but uh yeah as the clock ticks
down yes because they have played quite
uh slow in this game so far there must
be some time trouble coming yeah some
maybe it's just the nerves of being in
the final yeah and okay dude as rook
springs forward look at how active
black's rooks are right now some
pressure also on those pawns that we
just mentioned
white's queen side pawns normally you do
want to push pawns on the side you're
stronger but
here it's not so easy to defend them
and okay magnus has to push this point
forward but that pawn as well could come
under some fire from the black rooks
this one extremely tense and
i don't know who's gonna favor if both
players tick down under one minute
shortly and uh tuna from norway just
donated 106
dollars wow i can see people from all
over the world here angela from greece
donated nine dollars thank you so much
and please if you do have the
opportunity please donate to our
fundraiser for unicef all money
fundraised in this
fundraiser will be given to unicef and
their very important work in and around
ukraine for the people and children
affected by the horrible war going on
so please only today and tomorrow left
to uh make your contribution so please
help us
help unicef
meanwhile duda's still thinking
okay he needs to speed up maybe one of
the black rooks can go to the third rank
to hit this white pawn that has just
moved
struggling to find other ideas here for
black
uh i don't think you really want to move
the black knight right now it looks too
strong black bishop as well guarding the
pawn in the center just
process of elimination there's not many
other things you can do maybe it has to
be something with the black rooks but
duda
he's kind of frozen he's uh spent about
half his remaining time on this one move
i mean i've been there myself pontus i'm
a time travel addict i know you you like
to have these long things uh as well do
you guys have sort of a similar style
when it comes to time trouble yeah when
it comes to time travel
definitely
uh i think
david is actually worse than me
but uh
he is he's playing more so we can say
also so he's handling it better as we
could see in poland you know where you
are when you start in time travel you
know blitz
championship
but then i mean dude here do you think
this is the type of position that's easy
to handle with not that much time he's
under one minute now wow
not easy at all um
no uh you definitely do have to spend a
little bit of time working out
how you're going to continue the problem
is like you say is that now it's under a
minute and as the time starts ticking
down
um i don't know how you guys are but i
tend to stop panicking
especially
when the clock hits under 30 seconds i
actually spend a lot of time looking at
my clock ticking down
that's a very bad tactic you know that's
extremely bad technically
you know this uh spanish player ohm's
palace who freezes every time he's below
a minute yes freeze yeah then he doesn't
make any moves
and that tactic is not very great no
it's not a great tactic i mean me and
david we're a little bit different
we don't have problems any move is
better than no mover exactly exactly so
until you have zero you don't have any
problems yeah you're so used to it also
i think it's a lifestyle you know this
yeah it's definitely a bad well it's a
habit i'm not sure it's probably a bad
one but uh okay meanwhile a couple of
moves black's knight retreated so dude
now under 20 seconds he froze a bit he
retreated his knight not to a great
square and white star squad bishop is
actually putting some pressure now on
some pawns
okay he's going after white's pawns now
on this left flank can't the white rook
just slide over and defend the pawn
that's under attack and suddenly you
know white can even think about pushing
those pawns and look at the power of
those two bishops
yeah it's incredible yeah white's light
squared bishop controls all the light
squares actually right now and uh okay
he offers a trade of rooks as well very
natural white's dark square bishop
actually keeping an eye on two black
pawns also the black knight kind of
stuck where it is if the black knight
moves out the way white's bishop is just
going to go and grab black's remaining
pawn on this left side and okay i think
jovanka's move was maybe the more
ambitious of the two keeping the rooks
on
but uh duda okay pushing pawns now
creating a path as well for the black
king wow
magnus with the three minutes left on
the clock is this the time for him to
not play
the perfect best moves but to play the
most i will have you on christoph think
exactly exactly create some small
threats here and there just improve your
pieces on every turn
it's not exactly clear what black wants
to do next these pawns look impressive
in the center for black but they're
stuck with dark squares they block in
their own bishop so i i here would
probably try and move the white light
squared bishop by the way bring the
white king towards the center
um he needs to try and keep a bit of
extra time on the clock at least yeah
this one
yeah with best play maybe still balanced
but white is the one who can try to
create the threats there is there is a
big threat though in the position uh for
duda and that is uh to trade off the
dark squad bishops ah maybe that's his
plan yeah so he's guarded his central
pawns the two black pawns in the middle
guarding each other and next the black
bishop can indeed move back i mentioned
it was a bad piece so we can take step
back to the e7 square next to the black
king
trade off those dark square bishops that
would really ease black's task yeah
that's his plan you know but there is
also a lot of things going on because
but also magnus
thing is like you said before david you
know he can he can always bail out you
know with with taking the knight yeah so
if if he sees that there's any kind of
problems it's going to be a draw mm-hmm
yeah so magnus has that safety net right
yeah he has a safe internet but now i
think he's thinking about moving the
poor one of the pawns uh that he has
maybe
the one behind
the bishop yes yes because it's gonna be
now it starts to get really interesting
yeah it's really sharpening up this game
and uh despite the fact there's not that
much material left it's so tense there's
imbalances with pawn structure
imbalances with the piece yeah uh
configuration and okay magnus was one
and a half minutes i think you're right
there he has to maybe just push a pawn
he could make an argument for trading
rooks but that's risky if white captures
the blackbrook black recaptures with the
pawn black's pawn is only two squares
away from promotion
it can be stopped by those two bishops
but
you have to weigh up the risks with one
minute left allowing your opponent's
pawn uh down to the third rank
that looks risky plus i guess then you
have to use your bishop's defending
instead of attacking good point kaia and
uh that's not going to be a very
attractive for magnus um what other
i like
i like your suggestion of uh just uh
destabilizing those two pawns in the
center yeah and and then also it kind of
invites the white king into the game as
well
yeah i like it too so the move we're
looking for here maybe is for white to
step forward with the e pawn one square
undermine black's stronghold in the
middle and uh yeah it's hard to find
alternatives really i think it's that
one or a rook trade yeah but it's also
this you know how hard do you want to
play in the first game you know it's
always this you know because magnus
knows it's a long match
so it's always this like you know the
first you know how it is when you play
match you just played one with neil
stern in london yeah you know the first
game
you you usually don't want to lose that
yeah neither side wants to lose it's a
disaster to lose uh winning is nice but
it's not it's not going to win the match
immediately so
yeah some safety first options sometimes
but magnus surprisingly trading the dark
squared bishops off and it was on
black's terms so
the reason we wanted to kind of leave
the dark squared bishops on is because
after black captured the white bishop
white's pawn could have recaptured maybe
attacking the black knight gaining some
time
magnus now shaking his head also in time
trouble yeah he spent a lot of time 10
seconds for magnus but suddenly the
black king's great but that's a very
surprising move i don't know why he did
this yeah i don't know either and
suddenly black's knight is not a bad
piece at all
exactly it's going to start jumping into
white's uh camp okay magnus is going
after blacks pawns on the king side on
the right side
but very minimum duda could trade those
rooks off
and maybe he can just i don't think you
can really ignore this threat but maybe
he can trade the rooks off start jumping
in with the black knight
okay it's still really really tense both
sides at 15 seconds oh wow do disappear
bishop versus knight normally it favors
the bishop with pawns on both sides of
the board but here black has really
strong advanced central pawns and
black's king is the more centralized of
the two
okay this one is still could go either
way all three results yes he has also
this idea to go for the the prawns there
on the kings
of course like always minus c is more
so
we can't be surprised about that yeah
but uh he's good in these types of
positions i think it's this is you know
i i i can't see i would never play this
but i really do think that uh
duda has actually maybe made some a few
inaccuracies because he jumped forward
with the knight and allowed the white
pawns to start advancing and that i find
quite worrying and
taking the center as well those pawns
i've sat next to david for quite a long
time now
and now i'm always a little bit scared
if you're if you advance your pawns too
hastily yeah so at least duda has a
concrete idea in mind if the white king
us about say if it goes towards these
black pawns in the center black can step
forward with the pawn giving check
forcing the white king back
and uh okay magnus allows this in order
to try and create a path in for the
white king towards uh the black pawns so
the h5 square now isn't guarded white's
king could maybe sneak in there white's
going to try and play on both sides of
the board okay black's king this is
called what we call the opposition
blocking off shouldering off the white
king not letting it advance it's in the
eye line of the the bishop though really
risky but magnus shaking his head
he needs to play on both sides somehow
push his two pawns on the left and
create something here on the right side
because bishops will be so good at uh
kind of supporting h5 yeah the point is
gonna come and check the king now
and then forced back again and
maybe black doesn't need to commit
anything on this on this side of the
board now that tension maybe it does
favor black maybe black can just move
the king one square
what do you guys think will this end up
with a winner or a draw
ah it's hard to call right it's still
really tense still uh
yeah it's still super tense you know and
then one big one big mistake from any
side and you let loose you know yeah so
i
i think the winners are us you know
the same game
[Laughter]
chess is the winner
and yeah pontus you're exactly right
because if white makes a mistake black's
central pawns might just march down the
board make a new queen if black makes a
mistake those two versus one advantage
i've been talking about for a while on
the queen side that will favor white so
still everything to play for stakes are
still very high um the one scenario that
might end up in a draw is if all the
pawns get traded but how is that going
to happen
there are porn kind of advantages upon
majorities on for both sides on
different uh flanks so is can black get
really ambitious and try to
decoy the white king and go into the
center okay
duda giving a check with his knight
king has to take a step backwards and
then the big issue is do you maintain
your central pawn i think you had to and
duda says yes
okay so black's knight going back to
defend central pawn also black's knight
is currently holding up white's
advantage over there on the left flank
so white can no longer push forward upon
without it being without one of the
pawns being captured
so big question for magnus is he going
to repeat the position is white's king
going to go back to where it came from
earlier
that would allow duda to continue
repeating this okay second time we've
seen this position
if black's knight gives a check we might
be heading towards that draw maybe both
sides are just a bit stuck it's like
basically mutual zugzwang as we call it
where neither side can improve their
position without taking big risks or
without worsening their chances so both
sides are happy to actually just repeat
and uh also pontius you mentioned first
game neither side wanting to lose so
again it's the second time we've seen
this position as well white's king
previously went back to the h2 square is
magnus gonna do that again under 10
seconds
no he chooses a different square and wow
he's giving up a pawn with check
this is playing with fire did you see
doodle's direction yeah it was like what
he was that was my reaction as well you
know so
and uh duda just repeats moves i mean he
could have taken the pawn with the check
but then this would have involved the
knight being at the edge of the board
maybe too far away from white's past
pawns on the left magnus is really
playing for the win so he could have
forced the draw instantly by pushing his
king up one square that would have been
the third time we saw that position but
uh no he traded a set of pawns and he's
really trying to open things up now
there is a super interesting classical
move
you know uh one pawn forward there uh
just on the same flank same row as the
the
both pawn pushes were very interesting
yeah because you you get like some kind
of uh bind now it's it's quite
interesting this and the evaluation's
gone up in black's favor maybe that's
because all of the white pawns are stuck
on light squares
they can all be blockaded i think magnus
plays really hard you know
to win and i'm not this could easily i'm
not i'm not i'm not very convinced over
how hard he plays you know that he's
actually right in this position you know
i yeah magnus is like like now for
instance he's put his king away so maybe
the knight can actually step forward and
uh i'm always thinking about
breakthroughs and maybe there could be a
central pawn breakthrough at the right
time because
okay and uh yeah does play it goes for
it you know this is very dangerous for
for
now dude is the one playing for the win
whoa and okay here it comes okay only
one move for white i think you have to
retreat your bishop back to the bottom
of the board if you capture this pawn
with your own pawn black's e pawn breaks
through you cannot capture this pawn
it's poisoned that would end up in a
passport for black so you have to just
take a step back with your bishop but
oh that's ugly to b or d he takes it he
takes it giving up his bishop so after
the black knight recaptures
magnus he's gambling on his two pawns on
the left side there are they quick
enough
maybe they are
okay white pushes pawns
wow this is so hard to calculate right
now if this pawn is captured okay he
does take back in this way i was gonna
say maybe he could have run forward with
the white a pawn for but that would have
been too slow yes goes back oh and then
magnus is hoping that despite the fact
he's a knight down this white pawn on
the left side is going to completely uh
occupy the black knight and if we see a
trader pawns if black's king takes this
white pawn white's king will snap off a
porn as well and
maybe there's no way to pick off white's
remaining pawn in the center black's
only winning hope is to promote his pawn
his remaining pawn but how do you do it
first you go back with the knight and
see nothing happens
yeah exactly you know that's the number
one you always do and then you hope that
you have something
this is a miraculous draw though if
magnus holds it there no i think he is
holding it because the black knight
cannot help its king go and round up
white's pawn in the center the black
knight is completely stuck
oh wow wait so now young christopher is
looking for a win yeah and magnus is
hoping for a draw magnus cannot win this
one unless duda gets too ambitious and
moves the knight away allowing white to
make a new queen but
it's a strange way for magnus to make a
draw this is one of the weirdest draws
i've ever seen
just giving up and i mean he gave up his
bishop earlier willingly
and uh he must have calculated ahead he
must have figured out that there's just
no way through for like five seconds
okay the black king is going to try and
take the long way round towards the
white pawn but the problem is now the
white king comes closer
if black's remaining pawn drops it's
just a draw well he's hoping to win on
time because
you see this is the uh
the way to do it you know hoping that
dude that gets too ambitious and he will
win on time yeah
exactly sometimes the opponent
yeah okay let's ignore the evaluation by
there it's unless it says plus 100 we
won't trust that he's winning for black
uh it feels like almost a fortress type
of thing for white if the black king
goes to the left the white king also
will follow it
and just no way for the black king to
make its way around towards white's
yeah it's it's gonna be a draw but it's
it's funny funny also how hard the
magnus plays you know yeah because i
mean neither you and me will play like
this in the first game now so risky what
makes it so risky you know and and
and to survive by the skin of his teeth
like this
but what i mean my thing is though what
was magnus's point of doing all this
i think maybe magnus
had miscalculated i think he wanted to
run with his a pawn forward but the
black knight could have kind of checked
and hopped back dude i did not repeat
here they're not repeating but the
problem is now the black king is
completely frozen it has to guard its
own pawn and also the black knight has
to stop the white pawn so both black's
pieces are actually tied down
and uh yeah if black's pawn drops as
mentioned a knight on its own cannot
deliver checkmate
so uh yeah like this there is no way to
do it you know two stretched the black
knight yeah just
not able to do two roles not able to go
on the attack against white's pawns and
stop that white b pawn yeah
so in the end the computer is always
right 0.00
it doesn't matter the path and the drama
to get there
oh i mean it's a really high quality
game with some interesting moments but
yeah magnus i mean
most mere mortals would have panicked
there and uh he nearly pushed himself
too far
but saving the day and dude uh
five seconds
he would just take a few more moves i
think to realize uh okay there's no way
forward nothing to do and i think we're
about to see that result come in ah yeah
there we go position repeats itself it's
a draw first
game with king forever
continue to move
both